Este martes Finlandia se convirtió en
miembro de la organización para el
tratado del Atlántico Norte otan debido
a la guerra en Ucrania puso fin a
décadas de no alineamiento militar
la otan fue creada el 4 de abril de 1949
como una alianza de defensa colectiva en
su nacimiento estuvo formada por 12
países que coincidían en ver a la unión
soviética como una amenaza después
entraron Grecia Turquía Alemania y
España y en 1999 llegarían los primeros
satélites de la ya extinta Unión
soviética Hungría Polonia República
Checa en 2004 accedieron siete países
donde destacaban aliados soviéticos del
Pacto de Varsovia y las ex repúblicas
soviéticas bálticas como letonia
lituania y Estonia fronterizas con Rusia
la ampliación terminó con las anexiones
de Croacia y Albania en 2009 la de
Montenegro en 2017 y la de macedonia del
Norte en 2020 y ahora Finlandia en 2023
31 países en total el kremlin reaccionó
a la llegada de Finlandia y dice que su
adhesión supone un riesgo para la región
la otan está tomando una serie de
medidas para aumentar la preparación
para el combate de las armadas conjuntas
están intensificando el entrenamiento de
combate y las actividades de
reconocimiento cerca de las fronteras de
Rusia y velarús por supuesto todo esto
crea riesgos de una escalada
significativa del conflicto Vladimir
Putin ha acusado a la otan de violar su
supuesta Promesa de no expandirse más
allá de sus fronteras de 1990 Rusia
exige que el bloque occidental adquiera
compromisos en materia de seguridad
rechazando una eventual integración de
Ucrania a la alianza militar y el retiro
de la infraestructura militar instalada
en Europa del este después de 1997
Suecia sigue a la espera de la
aprobación por parte de Turquía para
convertirse en el siguiente miembro de
la alianza